everybody it's Charlie this is gonna be
my flash episode 16 video there are a
bunch of Easter eggs and obviously all
kinds of crazy time travel so I'll try
to explain what's going on because we're
in the final block of episodes you can
also tell how they're zeroing in on an
even bigger villain so to speak then the
film that we've been seeing all season
long the regular version of cicada
will do a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment
about the episode on the video starting
at the beginning number 10 with
reverse-flash and Nora so they're
talking to each other about their plan
reverse-flash is getting pissed off
Nora's worried that she did something
wrong but it's not completely her he
says he's paired the timeline from
anthro the first boy - Kamandi the last
characters who are both lost in time in
the comics as part of Final Crisis so if
it seems like they're laying in some
final crisis Easter eggs and people lost
in time I think they're foreshadowing a
little bit about what's happening on the
flash this season with cicada because
you have people that are plucked out of
time like perverse flash Nora in now the
future version of grace who's taken the
mantle of cicada so those are just east
drags from the comics I don't think
they're actually gonna bring those
characters on or anything like that
they're just foreshadowing stuff and
then obviously you have to remember the
Batman Final Crisis ending with him
being lost in time at the end of that
story in what's happening with Oliver
Queen in them ending the arrow show
after the crossover so just laying a bit
of seeds for a big story twist that they
can pay off later on number 9 though he
says the timeline is changing again he
says something is getting ready to break
through now we know because of the twist
at the end of the episode that he was
referring to Grace who came from the
future and took cicada and is gonna
create this whole new timeline and
things will be just as bad if not worse
when he go back to present day back at
STAR Labs there's a couple funny
references to what happened in last
week's episode iris is working on an
insurance case talking about guerilla
attacks this is a reference to Gorilla
Grodd vs. king shark last week there was
a little bit of Joe stuff going on
during the episode but it wasn't quite
as critical until the end of the episode
when they found out about grace being a
metahuman
so number 8 though the Nora themed flash
coffee in the list quote-unquote so
everybody has a list like Captain
America's list of all the things that he
wants to do now that he's unfor
and her flavor of coffee has the little
Flash symbol from her suit and it's
called expresso as an excess espresso
some of the items were cut off on their
list but the grandma is just a food dish
of the grandma Esther's that she wants
to teach her skiing sneaking on to the
jitters roof ziplining eating at
Sebastiaan OHS I think that that was
where Barry and iris went on a date once
Star Wars movie marathon pretty
self-explanatory
laser tag pretty funny teach Nora how to
drive I'm sure that would be pretty
hilarious camping pretty straightforward
karaoke reminds you of Flash karaoke
from way back in season one and then
obviously midnight screening of Rocky so
I'm sure that there's some other things
that they'll do from this list before
the end of the season number seven they
introduce a brand new character from the
comics acid master is sort of like a D
or F List villain from Action Comics
number 348 in 1967 he only appeared in
the comics twice and when Cisco makes
fun of his name his last name is master
that's actually right out of the comics
too so he very low-level villain not
that big of a deal number six was the
Joe and Cecile buddy-cop routine that
they did I wasn't really sure which
direction they were gonna take this they
played it for a little bit of comedy but
they've been really trying to lean on
Cecile's character especially when Joe
was away so she was sort of like the
stand-in for storylines that they would
normally give to him take it or leave it
I don't really care if they work
together I mean it's okay they don't get
that many scenes so it's not that big a
deal but they used their storyline to
talk to the doctor so they can find out
the Grace is turning into a metahuman
because of the shrapnel in her head
number five noir explains the importance
of the legacy of the flash this is
actually a really big deal because
remember she is like the biggest flash
fangirl in the future she spends all of
her time at the flash Museum so she's
basically reading the greatest hits from
all the Flash's adventures back to Barry
remember the time when you did this or
that going on and on and on so you can
kind of see how Barry has gotten a
little more cynical over the last couple
of seasons because what's happened so
she's mostly here to inspire him or try
to inspire him because she's trying to
get this plan on track but this season
to the flash is all about legacy for
everyone the legacy of the flash the
legacy of the reverse-flash he actually
mentioned that in the first episode that
he appeared in this episode is mostly
focusing on the legacy of cicada which
is the Grace character and when they say
failure is an
in the title of the episode the full
quote is victory has a hundred fathers
in defeat is an orphan and it just means
that many people will seek credit for
success but few will accept
responsibility for failure so in the
context of this episode it's a bit of a
metaphor and a literal thing because
grace is an orphan and she is their
failure in the future because she's his
crazy serial killer number four Sherlock
has most of Nora's time Journal decoded
and he started openly challenging her in
conversation while the group is together
the timeline is malleable she doesn't
seem to notice any of that though so
this getting ready to blow up in her
face in next week's episode the title of
the episode is aptly named time bomb
there was a brief scene towards the end
of the episode before future grace
cicada busted in where he started to
talk to her a little bit about it before
they got very far then things went off
the rails but based on the trailer for
next week's episode it sounds like it's
either the a or the B storyline because
there is a meta that they have to deal
with during the episode in addition to
all the cicada stuff but I think the
real focus of the episode is in Nora
telling Barry about the reverse-flash
and what she's doing with him there was
also a really good pep talk scene
between Joe West and Barry in his lab
just like season 1 it felt like a very
season one scene and it just reminds you
how much the show is weaker when Joe
isn't around the funny twist is though
is that Barry also gives him a little
bit of advice for cecile he says go
Barry you gotten really good at these
pep talks there was also a couple lines
of dialogue that reminded me about baby
Jenna remember Joe in Cecile's baby that
we haven't really seen that much of this
season don't you wonder what the purpose
of that baby is if we never see it if
it's gonna be some character in the
future that Nora is gonna hang out with
or if it was just some story device to
sort of create some drama and gives the
seal something to do for a little while
on the show and then they decided not to
double down on that like okay we'll just
put the baby over here and we won't ever
bring it on the TV show because we don't
care about it anymore who knows but if
we don't hear about the baby by the end
of the season then this confirmation
that they've officially just kind of
shuffled that plotline off into the
background never to be heard from again
three Barry convinces cicada to take the
Cure by going Barry Allen and getting
past the flash of it all so like
obviously it was foreshadowing him
taking his mask off when he had that
conversation with Joe show him the Barry
Allen side of things it all turned on
what was going to
happening with grace it was really
learning the grace was turning into a
metahuman that convinced him it wasn't
so much the Barry Allen stuff it was the
gray stuff because he obviously said he
doesn't care about his legacy he doesn't
care what happens to him so he takes the
cure it works exactly the way that it's
supposed to but number two future
Grace's cicada bust through the window
while Sherlock is getting ready to out
Nora and things go completely off the
rails she kills the doctor and you get a
good look at how her different powers
work and it seems like her powers are
very similar to the powers that cicada
has with the dagger only she doesn't
need the dagger so she gives out the
same type of red energy she can
immobilize people for as long as she
wants it also kind of seems like she has
a measure of super strength she's a
little bit quicker and she has those two
special daggers - cicadas one dagger
that she can use to deflect Speed Force
energy so they just want to let you know
that she is the upgrade villain cicada
was bad but she's even more powerful and
seems even more crazy so number one she
takes the kada back to their old house
as I missed you uncle takes the mask off
in its surprise big Smallville Easter
egg
you may remember Sarah Carter from
Smallville she played Alicia Baker the
one who could teleport because next
week's episode is leaning so hard on the
reverse-flash nora reveal and the time
bomb meta who has nothing to do with
cicada it seems like we won't pick up
with the cicada storyline or future
grace for another two weeks
but obviously everybody's wondering how
she was able to travel back in time if
it has something to do with her powers
or if there was another meta from the
future that was helping her out either
way she found a way to break through and
come back in time and now she's changing
things and that's what the reverse-flash
was talking about at the beginning of
the episode so let me know in the
comments what did you think about the
big twist at the end what do you think
about Sarah Carter coming on the show is
future Grace I think it's actually
pretty solid casting because when she
was on Smallville the Alesha character
that she played was also a little
unhinged and future gray cicada seems
completely batshit crazy so I am really
looking forward to seeing her go
completely off the deep end but the
whole idea here is that they're trying
to save young grace so that she never
turns into evil grace of the future
what'll happen is is I'll do a flash
trailer video and I'll name a giveaway
winner when I post that there's also a
new Marvel and new Game of Thrones stuff
coming leave your requests or your big
questions about the episode in the
comments
I'll try to address that during my
trailer video while you wait for
everything click here for a breakdown of
brand new Avengers endgame trailer
footage with Captain Marvel in it and
click here for my Captain Marvel
post-credit scene video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]